Mike what is the future of neuroscience
that's a great question I think we can
look in the past we can look at the past
of neuroscience and there's this frame
called functional localization this idea
that if we can point to brain region we
can figure out what it does or if we can
point to a neurotransmitter like
dopamine that there's a simple story and
these I think are wrong this is a we
need to move away from that so it the
the story that's kind of arising here is
the future of neuroscience is
understanding the brain's principles of
self-organization the sort of internal
logic of how the brain builds itself so
we have Qri we're looking at three
principles for students free energy
principle the brain tries to minimize
surprise you can do a lot with that an
incredible amount connectomes specific
harmonic waves this idea that the brain
self-organizes around its natural
resonances you can also do a lot of that
and then third neural annealing that
much like you can heat a metal up and
change it and then as it cools down
these new patterns sort of crystallized
and become durable that's perhaps how
the brain updates itself now of course
the details are involved here but that's
what really good at nice so the energy
efficiency seems like a very common one
that we're all aware of and then the
resonance so for each person what they
find most resonant and then annealing so
our ability to then take and change our
mind and have that settle in as
afterward so these are some of the new
and there's so many more right yeah
exactly and the idea is that if we can
actually figure out what principles the
brain uses to to function then we can
say
in a much more precise way about what
it's actually doing in any specific case
and why it's doing that
and of course if we can do that we can
figure out better ways to intervene to
to fix problems and then the cataloguing
the state speed of consciousness and
navigating it as well with little
dissonance is also a part of that future
absolute as well and being able to look
at it psychedelics and meditative States
and symmetrical states in this process
these are all parts of what your eyes
doing with the Future game of science
and it's all tied together the more we
know about one part of the puzzle the
more we can infer about all the rest yes
yes